wet roll ketchup double dog
ignore
the mountain of bread
[Music]
hello everyone i am jack settlemen
two-time champion of the punishment
league but unfortunately in week four i
am the loser russell wilson he played
well everyone wanted derek henry against
the jets devonta adams missed her
touchdown every single week last year so
i pay up for devonta adams and who
scores two touchdowns randall freaking
cobb but what pains me even more than
that i spent forty nine thousand and
nine hundred dollars i was one hundred
dollars away from upgrading adams to
tyree kill and i didn't do it and now i
have to attempt to eat 20 hot dogs in 20
minutes it's time to punish myself
oh no
the bread is going to be the hardest
part oh let's drop them one down
so joey chestnut
ate 74 of these in 10 minutes
and i liked hot dogs
two down
and i'm like two minutes in
one piece
i am prep for the loneliness that this
will be
no one's talking to me i'm essentially
talking to myself
huh
three down it's kind of easy
well my mom always told me though never
fill up on bread i kind of want to do a
double glizzy shot here
i'm not having fun
i do have this in case of emergency i've
um
about four and a half so far
is for you randall cop
i don't like that
that was oh of course second win
the double glizzy has been the best
strategy i know
all people on the app and on instagram
you'll be like oh you didn't finish any
bread you finish the bread then you do
the challenge all right
i'm gonna go with some ketchup i know
it's probably not strategic but
i don't even like ketchup that much
the pile of hot dogs i have to eat
is not shrinking this is for you
will dislike
two catches
there a way to make yourself burp let me
look that up
can you
make yourself work here we go
yeah i knew that wasn't gonna go well
10 minutes down
[Music]
what the heck
the feds are on line one they said you
can't eat this many hot dogs so if i
finish
this bite of seven down
to like 11 minutes which is a good pace
i'm proud of that pace
oh come on come on
is there anything else coming out with
that burp besides there
come on big bird
oh i can't do it we're going back to the
double dog strat
the only way to do it
oh
now i'm just eating mustard
this is
one of the most vile things i've ever
experienced
i really feel like i'm gonna throw up
pretty soon
i was excited
this is where i got left of the a4
clear i couldn't get a whole home run i
think i might throw in the white tail
soon this is number eight
shout out to lamar jackson he's number
eight he's the baby goat i'm the baby
goat of eating hot dogs
eight hot dogs 20 minutes
you can't beat that
no one watching this
can beat that score next sunday i will
win the punishment league because i
never
ever i'm going through something like
this ever again
[Music]